oh yeah we used to talk a lot I mean I'm
pretty sure it's because she had no one
else to talk to you but now it's like I
don't even exist hello hi hello Xbox
thing the office
which is fine I mean it wasn't like we
were best friends or anything okay maybe
we were but she's so annoying sometimes
I guess that's how friendships are you
know hey do you wanna maybe air air air
there when I do actually need to talk to
her I had to devise a plan so that she
would actually pay attention to me so
this is what I came up with
Xbox bang hi all right I'm just gonna
keep this short I just need your half of
the rent check Xbox Bing rent Xbox Bing
flightcheck
and that my friends is my roommate but
about me come on girl find me a new
roommate now
the tipple bear and about me about me
because with me look old I really think
this one through